Wenn du Gemüse oder Fleisch einkochen möchtest,
dann ist Botulismus eine Sache, mit der dich
auf jeden Fall auseinandersetzen solltest
beziehungsweise eigentlich musst.
Es ist mir wirklich ein ganz großes Anliegen
darüber zu sprechen, denn in Deutschland
ist das noch weitestgehend unbekannt.
In anderen Ländern ist es total normal, dass
man darauf achtet, dass man eben diese Botulismusbakterien
abtötet beim Einkochen.
Und bei säurearmen Lebensmitteln wie Fleisch
und Gemüse darauf achtet, dass man da Techniken
verwendet, die eben diesen Bakterien auch
zu Leibe rücken können.
In Deutschland ist das aber irgendwie überhaupt
kein Thema.
Ich weiß gar nicht woran das liegt, warum
wir da so rückständig sind.
Es sind relative neue Studien, die eben zeigen
wie gefährlich Botulismus ist und wie und
wo sich Botulismusbakterien in Eingekochtem
ausbreiten können.
Aber das ist etwas, wo wir jetzt ein Schlussstrich
ziehen und wo ich auf jeden Fall auf diesem
Kanal darüber sprechen möchte.
Denn wenn du deinen Liebsten etwas auftischst,
das du selber haltbar gemacht hast, das aus
deinem eigenen Garten kommt, wo du so viel
Liebe reingesteckt hast, wo du ja auch super
stolz drauf bist, dass du es am liebsten der
ganzen Welt schenken möchtest, deiner Familie
das auftischst, dann soll das ja bitte nicht
potenziell tödlich sein.
Denn Botulismus ist in vielen Fällen tödlich.
Das ist selten.
Botulismus ist einer der schlimmsten Lebensmittelvergiftungen
überhaupt und die tritt selten auf, aber
sie kann eben auftreten in säurearmen Lebensmitteln.
Das heißt, wenn der pH-Wert, dessen was du
einkochst unter einem bestimmten Wert liegt,
dann ist das Ganze anfällig für Botulismus.
Das sind kleine Bakterien, die kommen so gut
wie überall vor, in der Erde, im Wasser,
auf dem Gemüse.
Das ist auch alles überhaupt kein Problem.
Problematisch wird es erst, wenn diese Bakterien
unter Luftabschluss in säurearmen Lebensmitteln
sich vermehren.
Das ist ihre Umgebung, in der sie sich vermehren,
in der sie sich wohlfühlen.
Und dann schütten die einen Giftstoff aus,
ein Toxin, dass potenziell tödlich ist.
Und da reicht dann auch schon ein kleiner
Löffel von deinem Gemüse, dass du selber
eingekocht hast, um Botulismus zu bekommen.
Und die Todesrate ist leider sehr, sehr hoch.
Es sterben immer noch jedes Jahr Leute in
Deutschland an Eingekochtem, weil sie nicht
richtig eingekocht haben.
Das ist natürlich sehr, sehr selten.
Also ich möchte da jetzt hier absolut keine
Panik verbreiten und niemanden scheu machen.
Einkochen ist eine supertolle Möglichkeit
deine Ernte haltbar zu machen.
Aber damit musst du dich auseinandersetzen,
wenn du selber einkochst.
Und du musst wissen, ab wann muss ich denn
das Ganze in einem Druckeinkochtopf haltbar
machen, und wann kann ich es ganz normal im
Wasserbad einkochen.
Was ich dann oft zu hören bekomme ist die
Aussage: Ja, aber wir kochen das Ganze doch
ein.
Dann sind doch die Bakterien tot.
Ja, im Prinzip stimmt das auch.
Diese Bakterien, diese Botulismusbakterien
sind aber besonders hartnäckig.
Die sterben erst ab Temperaturen von 120 Grad.
Und eine Temperatur von 120 Grad, die schafft
man in einem normalen Einkochtopf rein physikalisch
einfach nicht.
Das muss unter Druck passieren, deswegen braucht
man einen Druckeinkochtopf.
Ich kann euch gerne mal hier Ausschnitte von
meinem Druckeinkochtopf einblenden, damit
ihr seht wie der aussieht.
Ist ein ganz schönes Monstrum.
Die gibt es aber in allen möglichen Größen.
Es ist natürlich komplizierter mit so einem
Druckeinkochkessel einzukochen, denn der hat
alle möglichen Funktionen.
Sicherheitsventile, wo man sich wirklich auskennen
muss.
Denn da drinnen herrscht richtig Druck.
Und da kann, wenn man da nicht sachgerecht
mit umgeht, können da auch Unfälle passieren.
Also es ist wichtig, dass wenn du so einen
Topf verwendest, dass du dann auch weißt,
wie du mit dem umgehst.
Und in diesem Topf können eben so hohe Temperaturen
entstehen, die dann die Botulismusbakterien
und die Sporen abtöten, sodass du das Ganze
sicher essen kannst.
Und die Sache ist, ich wusste das ganz lange
nicht, weil es in Deutschland einfach nicht
zum Einkochenwissen unserer Nation gehört,
dass man so ein Teil verwenden sollte, wenn
man säurearme Lebensmittel einkocht.
Also ihr müsst euch keine Sorgen machen bei
Obst.
Obst enthält genug Säure, außer Bananen,
die würden nicht genug Säure enthalten.
Aber bei Obst könnt ihr ganz normal euren
normalen Einkochtopf verwenden.
Aber bei Gemüse und bei Fleisch eben nicht.
Und das wusste ich einfach nicht und ich habe
zum Beispiel dann ganz viele Bohnen eingekocht
aus meinem Garten.
Und das war so frustrierend, dann zu sehen:
Okay, ich kann die jetzt einfach niemandem
mehr vorsetzen, wo ich dieses Wissen habe.
Natürlich ist es unwahrscheinlich, dass irgendetwas
passiert.
Aber wenn die Möglichkeit besteht, dann kann
ich das doch nicht mehr verwenden.
Und deswegen bin ich auch super froh, dass
wir vor ein paar Jahren auf diesen Druckeinkochkessel
umgestiegen sind, weil wir uns darüber jetzt
einfach keine Gedanken mehr machen müssen.
Ich habe das auch, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe
ja einen Onlinekurs zum Haltbarmachen der
eigenen Ernte, und ich habe in meinem Kurs
diese unsicheren Anleitungen weitergegeben.
Weil ich das einfach nicht wusste und ich
hatte so ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Also jetzt haben wir das natürlich alles
sicher überarbeitet.
Der Kurs öffnet auch bald wieder.
Also wenn ihr in meinem Newsletter eingetragen
seid, dann kriegt ihr auf jeden Fall Bescheid,
wenn der wieder öffnet.
Falls ihr da teilnehmen wollt, freue ich mich
super arg darüber.
Aber das hat mir echt ein ganz schön schlechtes
Gewissen gemacht, dass ich da diese unsicheren
Anleitungen weitergegeben habe.
Eine Frage, die auch immer wieder kommt, ist
die: Wie erkenne ich denn, wenn ich jetzt
schon etwas eingekocht habe, ob da jetzt Botulismusbakterien
drinnen sind oder nicht?
Und die Sache ist, bei vielen anderen Sachen,
die in deinem Einkochglas schiefgehen, dann
merkt man das ja.
Weil sich dann der Deckel wölbt, weil der
Deckel, wenn man die Weggläser verwendet,
zum Beispiel nur noch lose aufliegt.
Und kein Vakuum mehr im Glas herrscht.
Aber bei Botulismusbakterien ist das eben
nicht zwangsläufig der Fall.
Ich will da jetzt nicht zu tief einsteigen,
aber es gibt zwei Stämme von Botulismusbakterien.
Der eine zersetzt Eiweiß, der andere nicht.
Und gerade dieser zweite ist eben so problematisch,
weil sich da das Vakuum weiter im Glas hält.
Weil man da auch kein Anzeichen erkennen kann
von außen, ob da drinnen jetzt Botulismusbakterien
sind oder nicht.
Und das macht das Ganze eben so heikel.
Das heißt, du das hinterher keine Chance
zu sagen: Okay, da sind jetzt Bakterien drinnen
oder nicht.
Also das ist echt eine ziemlich eine vertrickte,
vertrackte Angelegenheit.
Wenn du jetzt noch ganz viele zum Beispiel
Bohnen in deinem Schrank stehen hast, Bohnen
sind besonders anfällig für Botulismus übrigens,
dann würde ich dir empfehlen, wenn du die
noch essen willst, dass du die ungefähr 15
Minuten lang brodelnd kochst bevor du die
isst.
Das sollte die Toxine aus dem Essen rauskochen.
Die sind nämlich hitzeempfindlich.
Und dann kannst du das immer noch essen.
Aber richtig appetitlich ist das nicht, oder?
Wenn man weiß, da können potenziell tödliche
Gifte drinnen sein in meinem Essen.
Ich habe übrigens eine Checkliste erstellt
für alle von euch, die mehr von ihrer Ernte
haltbar machen möchten.
Sich mehr mit dem Thema Haltbarmachen auseinandersetzen
möchten, mehr lernen möchten, neue Techniken
lernen möchten, auch lernen möchten, wie
man sicher einkocht, da findet ihr hier ganz
viele Informationen.
Da fängt es erst einmal an mit Gemüsen,
die man im Winter anbauen kann.
Das ist natürlich auch total schön, wenn
man statt aus der Vorratskammer ganz viel
auch aus dem Garten essen kann.
Wildpflanzen, die man ernten kann.
Und hier findet ihr zum Beispiel auch eine
Anleitung zum Einkochen unter Druck.
Diese Checkliste könnt ihr euch gerne herunterladen.
Die haben ich euch einfach hier unten unter
dem Video in der Videobeschreibung verlinkt.
Eine Aussage, die ich immer wieder zu hören
bekomme, seit ich über Botulismus spreche
und auch über Botulismus schreibe, ist die,
dass Leute sagen: Ja, meine Oma hat immer
Fleisch und Bohnen im Wasserbad eingekocht
und bei uns ist auch nie jemand gestorben.
Und das ist eine Aussage, die ich ein bisschen
schwierig finde.
Weil natürlich ist es selten, dass Botulismus
passiert, aber früher hatte mein einfach
nicht das Wissen, dass das Ganze nicht im
Wasserbad eingekocht werden sollte.
Heutzutage haben wir das Wissen.
Es gibt moderne Studien.
Die kann ich euch gerne in die Infobox packen,
sodass ihr euch die auch anschauen könnt.
Die sagen: Nicht Gemüse und Fleisch im Wasserbad
einkochen.
Das ist nicht sicher.
Und es gibt Leute, die daran sterben.
Früher wusste man ja auch oft gar nicht,
wenn jemand gestorben ist woran das liegen
könnte.
Natürlich ist das nur selten passiert.
Aber es ist passiert.
Es passiert heutzutage immer noch.
Und ich finde, mit diesem Wissen, das wir
heutzutage haben, muss man dann eben auch
einmal alte Techniken über Bord schmeißen.
Und sich dem anpassen, um eben die eigene
Familie, die eigene Gesundheit zu schützen.
Dass es Botulismus gibt, war übrigens schon
im achtzehnten Jahrhundert bekannt.
Aber diese neuen Studien, die eben genau sagen,
wir brauchen diese 120-Grad-Grenze, die den
pH-Wert analysiert haben und getestet haben,
ab welchem pH-Wert können die sich denn vermehren
und ab welchem nicht, sodass man eben auch
sichere Rezepte entwickeln kann, die sind
relativ neu.
Und ich finde, wenn man eben diese Erkenntnis
jetzt hat, dann kann man eben sich auch dementsprechend
verhalten.
Wie gesagt, lasst euch nicht abschrecken.
Lasst euch nicht vom Einkochen abhalten.
Besorgt euch einen Druckeinkochkessel, wenn
ihr Gemüse oder Fleisch haltbar machen möchtet.
Im Moment sind die ziemlich ausverkauft, weil
wegen Corona eben eine riesige Nachfrage besteht.
Die werden vor allem in Amerika hergestellt,
weil es in Deutschland eben noch nicht wirklich
die Erkenntnis gibt, dass man diese Druckeinkochkessel
verwenden sollte.
Ich kann gucken, ob ich einen Link finde von
einem Kessel, der zurzeit verfügbar ist.
Dann, wenn ich einen finde, pack ich den in
die Videobeschreibung.
Ansonsten denke ich, dass in den nächsten
Wochen wieder neue Kessel produziert werden
sollten.
Also ja, es ist ziemlich abgegrast, der Markt
im Moment.
Durch das Coronavirus.
Und weil viele Leute eben jetzt noch mehr
selber anbauen wollen, mehr haltbar machen
möchten, ihren eigenen kleinen Wintervorrat
anlegen möchten und deswegen ist es gerade
ein bisschen schwierig an diese Kessel zu
kommen.
Aber ich gehe stark davon aus, dass sich das
bald wieder ändert.
Und wenn ich irgendwo ein Kessel finde oder
wenn ihr ein Kessel findet, dann schreibt
das gerne unten in die Kommentare.
Oder ich schreibe es in die Videobeschreibung,
ihr in die Kommentare.
Damit wir uns da gegenseitig weiterhelfen
können.
Für die Leute, die das Einkochen im Druckkessel
mal auszuprobieren: Wenn ihr wissen wollt,
welche Gemüse ihr mit welchen Techniken haltbar
machen könnt, Einkochen ist ja nicht die
einzige Technik da draußen, dann schaut euch
gerne dieses Video da drüben an.
Da unten verlinke ich euch meine Tour durch
unsere Selbstversorgervorratskammer.
Wenn euch das interessiert, schaut euch gerne
das Video da unten an.
Ansonsten sehen wir uns nächsten Samstag
wieder.
Wie immer um zehn Uhr hier auf dem Kanal.
Bis dann!
Tschüss!